Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Efendim, merhaba.
Gazetecilikle hayata başlamış,
otuz beş yıldır gazetecilik yapan,
2007'den beri son on yıldır da
Slow Food Türkiye'deki örgütlenmesinde
görev alan bir insan olarak karşınızdayım.
Bugün, hayatı yavaşlatmaktan bahsedeceğiz.
Çok güzel konuşmalar
dinledik sabahtan beri
ama Milan Kundera'nın "Yavaşlık"
kitabında bir hikaye vardır bilir misiniz?
Ne der Milan Kundura:
"Siz sakin sakin bir yerde otururken
ya da bir meydanda yavaş yavaş
etrafı seyrederken birisi yanınızdan
hızlı bir şekilde koşuyorsa,
hızlı bir şekilde hareket ediyorsa;
onun ya bir derdi vardır,
ya bir suç işlemiştir,
ya bir suç işlemeye gidiyordur.
Mutlaka bir sıkıntısı vardır.
Evet, Slow Food hareketi
sabahtan beri konuştuğumuz
bütün bu yavaşlık hikayelerini
Dünya'da ilk kez başlatan örgüt.
Örgüt mü? Dernek mi? Vakıf mı?
Bütün bunların hepsi!
Öte yandan da bir hareket,
yani bir insanlık hareketi, Slow Food.
Şimdi Slow Food'un bir sitesi var.
Evet Slow Food yıllarca
"İyi , Temiz ve Adil" sloganını kullandı.
Bundan vazgeçtik mi?
Vazgeçmedik.
Daha yavaş bir dünya, daha yaşanılır
bir dünya için, önce; daha iyi,
daha temiz, daha adil
gıdalara ihtiyacımız vardı.
Slow Food bunu tanımlıyordu.
Bu yıl değişti slogan.
Yeni bir sloganımız var:
"Yeryüzünü sev, geleceğini savun!"
Bir önceki oturumda da dile getirildi,
geleceği savunmak.
Slow Food gelecek için fikir yürütmüyor,
gelecek için ne olacak fütürizmi yapmıyor.
Slow Food engronun farkında
Oscar Ödül Töreninde,
gerçek bir faciaya yol açan
denetim şirketlerinin bile
özünde ne olduğunu çok iyi biliyor.
Ama Slow Food bütün bunların
dışında bakıyor dünyaya.
''Geleceği savun'' diyerek bakıyor.
Evet bizim dünyada,
bir milyon destekçimiz var.
100 bin kadar üyemiz var.
Biraz daha arttı sayısı,
üç bin yedi yüz yetmişti,
ben buna ilk hazırlığı yaparken.
Şu anda dört bini geçti.
Nuh'un Ambarı projemiz var ki
bugün ben ağırlıklı olarak
Nuh'un Ambarı'na götüreceğim sizi.
İki bin dört yüz food komitemiz var,
iki bin beş yüz, üç bine yaklaştı.
Afrika'da bahçe kurduk.
Orada ,insanlara başka
bir şeyler öğretmeye çalışıyoruz.
Bin beş yüzden fazla konviviyumuz var.
Konviviyum nedir?
Konviviyum Latince bir deyim;
"ocakbaşı" demek.
Bir sofranın etrafına toparlanıp,
yemek yiyen insanlar
ama bunu yerken bir yandan da
Dünya'yı düşünen insanların,
bir araya geldiği örgütlenme demek.
Beş yüz presidiomuz var,
presidio da şu:
Birazdan konuşacağız.
Bir yandan koruyalım
ama koruduğumuz ürünler,
onu koruyanlara para da kazandırsın.
Bunu,organizasyonu ve
160 ülkede örgütlüyüz şu anda.
Türkiye'deki konviviyumların
sayısı yirmi yedi.
Gördüğünüz gibi İzmir - Bardacık
konviviyumunun lideri bendenizim.
Şimdi ilk projemiz;
Gastronomi Bilimleri Üniversitesi.
Yani bu işin eğitim olmadan olmayacağına
inanmış Slow Food'un kurucuları.
Eğitim şart diyoruz.
Burada, eski bir şato.
Orası Gastronomi Bilimleri
Üniversitesi'ne çevrilmiş durumda
ve orada çok güzel işler yapılıyor.
Mesela; bugün doğaya çıkma günü;
10 Mart, üniversitenin bütün öğrencileri
topluca doğaya çıkıyorlar.
Oradaki, çevredeki; otları,
şeyleri tanıyorlar ve bu üniversitede
yaklaşık 40 ülkeden öğrenci var.
Sayısını arttırmaya çalışıyoruz.
İnşallah 2018-2019 öğretim yılında,
bu üniversitenin bir yüksek okulu,
Çeşme'de ya da Kuşadası'nda açılacak.
Çünkü buralarda çalışan
öğretim üyeleri gönüllü insanlar.
Gönüllü oldukları için de onlar çok
düşük paralarla çalışıyorlar.
Ama artık bıkmışlar, usanmışlar;
yağmurdan, kardan, soğuktan, buzdan.
Onları, böyle yılda 300 gün güneş
olan bir yere davet edince,
koşa koşa geliyorlar.
İnşallah Kuşadası'nda ya da Çeşme'de
bir okulunu açacağız bunun.
Bir başka etkinliğimiz;
Haziran'da ki Slow Cousine.
Bu tabii paralel olacak şeyde,
orada Slow Cousine başladığında,
biz Türkiye'de her yıl Haziran ayında,
Slow Cousine yapıyoruz
üniversiteye bağlı olarak.
Tabii İtalyan şarap kültürü,
dediğimiz bir kültür, orada yine
bu yılın etkinlikleri
içinde yer alıyor.
Yani eğitim, örgün bir eğitim aslında.
Yani onu böyle mümkün olduğunca
toplumun içine yayacak şekilde.
Sadece aşçı yetiştirmiyorlar.
Çok önemli bir hareketimiz var adı;
"Slow Food Gençlik Hareketi "
Gençlerden buna katılmak isteyen olursa
çıkışta benimle iletişim kursunlar.
Şimdi çok büyüdük,160 ülke olunca;
Slow Avrupa diye, Slow Asya,
Slow Amerika, Slow Okyanusya,
Slow Afrika diye örgütlenme, bölünerek
kıtasal bir dönüşüm yaşayacağız.
Şimdi Slow Avrupa yeni kuruldu.
Asya Afrika ve Okyanusya
daha sonra gelecek.
Slow Avrupa sitesine
girerseniz oradaki,
Türkiye'deki etkinliklerde
bunun içinde yer alıyor.
Şimdi bir de Balkan Masası kuruyoruz.
Balkan Masası kurulduğunda,
biz Slow Food'u 3 konviviyum
olarak kurduk.
Türkiye'de ilk kez bizim
İzmir "Bardacık",
İstanbul'da Defne Koryürek'in
kurduğu "Fikir Sahibi Damaklar"
bir de "Yağmur Böreği"
konviviyumu bir de biz.
"Bardacık" diye kurduk konviviyumuzu,
şimdi sayılar arttı.
Slow Avrupa'nın bir ayağı,
Balkan Masası şeklinde,
İstanbul'da çalışmaya başlayacak
bu yıl içerisinde.
Tabi ki önemli bir etkinliğimiz Slow Meat.
Et yiyoruz ,çok hoşumuza gidiyor falan
ama gerçekten et mi yiyoruz?
Bunun içinde hayvanların
özellikle beslenirken kullandıkları
silajlar, yapılırken kullanılan ürünler;
mısır, soya bütün bunlar.
Yani hayatı yavaşlatacağız ya,
önce ne yediğimizi
bilmemiz gerekiyor.
Slow Meat bu etin iyi, temiz
ve adil koşullarda üretilerek;
tüketiciye ulaşması için
başvurduğumuz bir yöntem.
Slow Fish.
Slow Fish İstanbul'dan kimse varsa
aramızda farkındasınızdır.
Hani senin ki kaç santimden başlayan;
ve daha sonra da,
Lüfer kampanyalarıyla dikkatinizi çekti.
Buralarda da üretici
ve tüketici çok önemli.
Üreticiyi çok önemsiyoruz.
Üreticinin haklarını savunuyoruz
ama üreticinin haklarının,
tüketiciyle beraber
savunulmasını istiyoruz.
Bu anlamda Slow Food'un bütün
dünyaya eklediği bir deyim var:
"Türetici."
Yani ne tüketici ne üretici,
hem üretici hem tüketici.
Bunu başarabilirseniz, hem üretici
hem tüketici olmayı, haklarınızı...
İşte lüfer kampanyası
bunun en iyi örneği.
Çünkü siz 20 cm'den küçük
lüfer alırsanız;
3 sene sonra alamayacaksınız.
Çocuklarınız hiç yiyemeyecek o zaman.
Ama balıkçının bunu
satması gerekiyor, üreticinin.
Öyleyse onu ikna etmeniz gerekiyor,
onu almamanız gerekiyor.
İşte türetici fikri burada
ortaya çıkan bir şey.
Ondan sonra, evet bizim tabii
bir vakfımız var.
Bu vakıf; Rotary Vakfından sonra
Dünya'da ki en güçlü vakıf.
Şu anda, kullandığı
argümanlar açısından
ve yaygınlık açısından;
Biyolojik Çeşitlilik Vakfı.
Bu Biyolojik Çeşitlilik Vakfında,
önemli etkinliklerden bir tanesi de;
"Yeryüzü Pazarları."
Bakın böyle bir daire var.
Bu dairenin içinde;
Türkiye'den üç tane Yeryüzü Pazarı var.
Diğer Yeryüzü Pazarları'nın olduğu
ülkeler siyaha alınmış durumda.
Türkiye'de üç Yeryüzü Pazarımız var.
İlkini Foça'da biz kurduk.
Yani İzmir'e bağlı olarak Foça'da önce
bir konviviyum kurduk "Zeytindalı" diye.
Sonra Yeryüzü Pazarları.
Yeryüzü Pazarı ne?
Ben ortada duruyorum
böyle bütün ürünler bana geliyor.
En uzak yer 20 km,
böyle de 20 km, böyle de 20 km.
40 km çapında daha
uzaktan bir şey gelmiyor.
O zaman ne oluyor?
O zaman gerçekten en düşük
karbon ayak izini yaratıyoruz.
Şimdi bunun Dünya'da
başka örnekleri de var.
Bir, kasabaları artık yavaş yavaş
getirmeye çalışıyorlar.
İnşallah Seferihisar bu konuda
ülkemizin ilk Çittaslow'u
olarak iş yapacak.
Fakat Çittaslowla, Slow Food'u
aman birbirine karıştırmayın.
İki kuzen, aynı dünyaya bakan.
Biri bir kentsel kalkınma modeli,
biri koruma modeli.
Bir karışıklık olmasın.
Dünyanın tek Ada Yeryüzü Pazarı
Gökçeada'da.
Müthiş bir örnek,
müthiş bir deneyim.
Bütün dünyadan insanlar
gelip, oraya gidiyor.
Çünkü; adanın dışında hiç bir yerde,
ilerde Seferihisar'ın
yapabileceği bir şey;
tuz, şeker ve çay dışında bir şey
gelmiyor Yeryüzü Pazarı çevresine.
Müthiş bir şey! Her şey adada;üretilenler,
ne kadar güzel bir şey değil mi?
Çünkü genetik olarak da öyle,
hekimler de bize hak veriyor.
Şayet dedenizin yediğini yerseniz,
anneannenizin yediğini yerseniz
oluyor bu işler.
Ve aynı şekilde şimdi;
Şile'de kuruldu.
Bir Ourtmarket nasıl oluşturulur
merak ediyorsanız;
benim yanıma beş dakika gelin.
Bir sonraki slaytımız.
Evet Afrika'da 10 bin bahçe kuruyoruz.
Bahçe kurmak çok kolay.
Evet presidiolar var.
Presodiolar da yavaş yavaş
bir kırsal kalkınma modeline
dönüştürdüğümüz para kazanma işleri.
Boğatepe Gravyer Prosediosu var ki;
Kars'taki gravyer dünyanın tartışmasız,
bütün hani gurme yiyenlerin
kendilerine tanımladıkları bir şey.
Dünyanın en lezzetli
gravyeri tartışmasız.
Aynı şekilde 2800 metrede üretiliyor.
"Zavot" denen çok özel bir ineğin
sütüyle üretiliyor o yüzden öyle.
Haziran'ın 20 ile Ağustos'un
5'i arasında üretiliyor.
Bir de yerin 300 metre
altında üretilen bir peynir;
yine Türkiye'ye özgü bir
zenginlik "Divre, Obruk Peyniri."
Karaman yakınlarında
obruklar var orada üretiliyor.
Sonra da tabi buğday.
Buğday, Canan Karatay hanım
çok doğru konuşuyor.
Buğday yememek lazım, ekmek,
buğday ekmeği yememek lazım.
İki tanesi hariç; Siyes ve Kavılca.
Çünkü insanoğlu ilk
tarım devrimini gerçekleştiğinde;
buğdayın 14 kromozonu vardı.
Şimdi biz 45, 47, 48
kromozomlu buğdaylar yiyoruz.
Yemememiz lazım.
O yüzden belki de
sürekli hızlanmaya çalışıyoruz.
Ama bozulmamış iki buğday,
sadece iki buğday Anadolu'da.
Biri Siyes, biri Kavılca.
Siyes Kastamonu'da, Kavılca Kars'ta.
Bunlar kuruduktan sonra örneğin;
Siyes Bulguru da normal bulgur gibi
3 liraya satılıyordu.
Şimdi 15 liraya satılıyor.
Çünkü insanlar bunu öğrendikçe,
onun peşine daha çok düşüyorlar.
Köylüde kalkınıyor ve çok değerleniyor.
Tabii daha çok ekilmeye başlanıyor.
Bu presidioların böyle bir fonksiyonu var.
Ve en önemli projemiz: "Ark of Taste"
Ark of Taste; Nuh'un Ambarı demek.
Evet gördüğünüz gibi bir gemi var:
Nuh'un gemisi.
Nuh peygamberin
bütün kutsal kitaplarda yazıldığı gibi
ürünlerini, bütün hepsinden
birer tane alarak yaptığı şey.
Ark of Taste'de şu anda bugün itibariyle
4188 benzersiz ürün,
kontrol altına alınmış durumda.
1352 tane de aday ürün var.
Bunların, 59 tanesi
Türkiye'den koruma altında.
Ne bunlar? Amerika'da da var,
gördüğünüz gibi, İtalya'da da var.
Ama ben bugün size
Türkiye'yi anlatacağım.
Ne bunlar? Kars'ın eski kaşarı,
Beyşehir'in tarhanası,
Bileke ekmeği, siyah mercimek,
böyle böyle gidiyor, Boğatepe gravyeri.
İşte Boğatepe gravyeri
az önce sözünü ettiğim örnek.
Benzersiz. Yani burası şu anda
yaşlanma aşamasında olan gravyerler.
Biz presedioyu kurana kadar
köylünün elinde kalıyordu,
Ben 15 gün önce
Karstaydım, hepsi bitmiş.
İlhan Koçulu orada bir
tarım devrimine imza atıyor.
Aynı şekilde devam edelim.
Çekme pasta Foça'dan, çerez tarhana...
Çerez tarhana diye bir şey var.
Çerez gibi yeniyor.
Divle'nin peyniri, Eğim'in pekmezi;
işte Eğim pekmezi duttan yapılan
benzersiz bir ürün.
Pekmez çok yemeyin
çünkü karamelize oluşu nedeniyle
şekerlenme nedeniyle
olumsuz etkileri var insan vücuduna.
Ama dut pekmezini yiyin.
Dut pekmezinde o karamelizasyon olmuyor.
Eğim pekmezi bu anlamda koruma
altına alınmış 59 üründen biri.
Havyar, hırsız çalmaz kavunu,
ne güzel değil mi?
O kadar iğrenç bir kavun ki
dışarıdan hırsız çalmıyor.
Ama öyle lezzetli ki...
Hurma zeytin.
Hurma zeytininin en iyisini,
Germiyan köyünde toplarsınız.
Alaça' da toplarsınız
müthiş bir lezzettir.
Urla'nın zeytinidir.
Evliya Çelebi Urla'ya geldiğinde,
hurma zeytin üzerine neler yazmış,
size dışarıda anlatayım.
Tabi ki İbnos gibi işte
Karaburun hurma zeytini.
Bu çok eski bir fotoğraf.
Şimdi 28 lira!
Bakmayın böyle durduğuna.
Çünkü, çünkü insanoğlu zeytin yemeyi
hurma zeytin sayesinde öğrendi.
Çünkü hurma dalında olan bir zeytin
hiç bir kimyasal işleme,
hiç bir olumsuz etkiye
gerek kalmadan yapılan zeytin.
Evet sevgili dostlar;
59 tane ürünümüz var.
Bunları hızlı geçeceğim.
Tabii ki bu buğday;
kavılca buğdayı. Çeşitli projeler...
Seferihisar'ın, çerez bebek, tarhanası
ya da sakızlı tarhana.
Çocuk hastalandı mı Seferihisar' da
bunu yedirirler hap gibi iyileşir,
o kadar önemli bir şey.
Türk kopan listesi;
bizim Ayşe teyze var Germiyan'da.
Ayşe teyze...
Türk kopan listesinde
iki malzeme vardır.
Süt ve emek. Süt ve emek.
Emek vermezseniz
Türk kopan listesi olmaz.
Ayşe teyze kırk gün yoğurur onu,
seksen gün yoğurur,
soğuk yıllarda ona ulaşır.
Şimdi bütün bunları anlatıyoruz
biyolojik çeşitliliği koruyalım.
Bütün bunların hakkından gelelim.
Slow Food biliyorsunuz;
İtalya'da 2015'de,
Expo Milano'da kendine
geniş bir yer ayırmıştı.
Ben de orada üç tane konuşma yaptım.
Bir tanesini Slow Food standında yaptım.
Orada insanlara dedim ki;
—Siz Atatürk'ü biliyor musunuz?
Karşıda bütün Slow Foodcular;
— Biliyoruz tabi duyduk, falan.
Pekte olumlu anlatmamışlardır
onu değil mi? Evet.
— Biliyor musunuz? Dedim.
Mustafa Kemal o kadar
önemli bir adamdır ki,
sizin, bizim 1987'den 1989'dan beri
anlatmaya çalıştığımız,
biyolojik çeşitliliği korumak için
1926'dan itibaren 1935'e kadar
o kadar önemli bir iş yapmıştır ki...
Sevgili dostlar Mustafa Kemal
1926 yılında,
İran Şahı İzmir'e geldiğinde
ona bir bahçe göstermek istiyordu.
Ve Türkiye'nin zeytin çeşitliliğini
göstermek istedi.
Haber saldı Türkiye'nin her yerine.
Her yerden Bornova' ya zeytinler geldi.
235 çeşit zeytin geldi Bornova'ya.
Hepsini işaretlettirdiler, yazdırdılar.
Hepsi duruyor orada.
Biz bugün o 235 çeşidin,
% 50 den fazlasını kaybettik;
üreticiliği koruyamadığımız için.
Ama Gazi müthiş bir öngörüyle,
Gazi müthiş bir vizyonla,
235 zeytin ağacını toplattı.
Bugün 80 küsur zeytinin
tarımı yapılıyor,
40 küsur zeytinin ticareti
yapılabiliyor Türkiye'de.
Ama Mustafa Kemal'in
izinden gidebilseydik,
sonraki nesiller hepsi korunmuş olacaktı.
Aynı şeyi incir için yaptı.
İncir için Erbeyli'de
Aydın-İncirliova yakınlarında;
bir köyde İncir
Araştırma Enstitüsü kurdu.
60 küsur incir çeşidini topladı
onun bahçesine.
Emirle yaptı bunların hepsini,
zaten emretmese olmazdı.
Sofralık üzüm için Manisa'da
Horozköy'de 80 den fazla sofralık üzüm
ve Sungurlu'da buğday
ve mübadelenin etkisinin
farkındaydı Gazi.
Mübadelede bütün
herkesin gittiğini biliyordu.
Rumlarla beraber Ermeniler ile beraber,
Anadolu'daki şarap çeşitliliğinin
yok olduğunu biliyordu.
Tekirdağ'da Süleymanpaşa'da
enstitü kurdurdu.
O enstitü yaşıyor bugün,
1490 şaraplık üzüm var.
Ben onu Fransa'da anlattığımda
milletin kafası uçuyor.
1490 şaraplık üzüm gövdesiyle,
yaprağıyla, tadıyla korunuyor orada.
1935'ten beri...
Ne kadar büyük bir vizyon değil mi?
O yüzden dedim ki;
biz boşuna konuşuyoruz.
Liderimiz Carlo Petrini,
çok önemli bir iş yapmıştır.
Hayatı yavaşlatmak,
hayatı daha yaşanılır kılmak,
hayatı daha güzel,
daha keyifli hale getirmek için;
Slow Food hareketini kurmuştur.
Ama mesele biyolojik
çeşitliliği korumaksa,
bunun başlatanı dünyada
bizden bir adamdır.
Bizim liderimizdir;
Mustafa Kemal'dir.
(Alkışlar)